vous êtes nombreux petits et grands à
nous écrire pour nous demander des
nouvelles de notre mascotte mabrouk
l'ami des enfants
mabrouk ne parvient plus à répondre
personnellement à tout son courrier il a
donc décidé d'adresser à tous ses fans
une carte postale télévisée chaque fois
qu'il le pourrait pour bien se porter il
faut d'abord se dégager des loisirs
mabrouk qui demandent pas un match de la
coupe d'europe des clubs a une
prédilection pour le ballon rond et
s'entraînent régulièrement au bois de
boulogne
mais le je n'exclus pas l'éducation tels
le sagace que vous faut
mabrouk au coeur de l'action se souvient
des leçons de son maître
les trottoirs sont une frontière que
l'on ne doit pas franchir inopinément
entre de récréation mabrouk s'entraîne
il n'a pour le moment suivi que quelques
cours mais se révèle déjà un élève
particulièrement doux est tout à fait
conscient de ses pouvoirs et de ses
responsabilités la voiture c'est déjà la
maison le territoire du maître est le
sien par la même occasion à un conseil
en passant que vous soyez contractuels
cambrioleurs ou simplement amateurs de
bolides observer de loin
l'objet de vos désirs s'il est gardé par
un cadre pas
souvenez vous que le sens de la
propriété n'est pas spécifiquement
humain
comme tous les bergers allemands ses
frères mabrouk a voulu connaître les
secrets de l'attaqué et de la défense
bien que son maître très discret ne se
montre que de dos vous pouvez constater
que mad rock ne le quittent par du coin
de l'oeil
il étend même sa protection à tous les
collaborateurs de l'équipe de france
ayant des goûts qu'on se le dise la
bronca non seulement le charme et le
prestige d'une star la nonchalance des
habitués des studios mais aussi à lui
seul l'efficacité et la force de
dissuasion d'une brigade canine un chien
de 40 kg comme mabrouk lancé à 40 km
heure à une force d'impact de 400 kg
quant à la pression des crocs d'un
berger allemand
elle est de 700 kg au centimètre carré
ses performances ne vont pas sans effort
quotidien mabrouk est un adepte fervent
du jogging au programme trot galop saut
d'obstacles le parcours complet du
parfait chiens sportifs
on murmure dans les coulisses de 30
millions d'amis qu'avec un tel
entraînement mabrouk aura bientôt la
forme olympique
déjà il s'entraîne pour une autre
discipline la natation la brasse
terre-neuve et la nage labrador n'auront
bientôt plus de secret pour lui vous le
voyez ici repérer les lieux de ses
futurs l'exploit nous vous montrerons
dans une prochaine séquence les
premières longueurs de bassin du nouveau
johnny ouest muller canne 1